[Music]
tessa and i are co-founders of norst
a loungewear label made sustainably by
heritage craft artisans
felicia runs a design studio called
quartus architects
that explores the creation of
experiences within art and architecture
pessa is a community development worker
at an ngo called mercy center working
with the homeless and marginalized
communities
[Music]
design comes alive when it serves a
purpose and addresses real human needs
so we ask
ourselves often what do we each bring to
the table
since both of us are architects by
training it shapes how we see studies
and approach the creative process
an architect draws plants as one seeing
from above
akin to an aerial view but every good
building
is experienced fully from the ground up
and from the inside out
[Music]
the national gallery is a building that
preserves heritage
in a way that is relevant to us today
adaptive reuse by conserving buildings
instead of demolishing them is
sustainable as it reduces carbon
footprint
light filters gently through the
reflective pool
lowering the temperature and creating an
immersive
moment of pause for a space to work well
it must be designed with real people in
mind
people who feel the warmth of sunlight
who hear footsteps on gravel
who grasp the textures of a handrail
space envelops us
similarly we see clothing not as
disposable fashion
but as something we inhabit how can
clothing become a comfortable
second skin that eases our daily
routines
[Music]
from a glance it is easy to write
singapore off as a commercial metropolis
filled with skyscrapers but the gritier
underbelly of shop house alleys
with delicious hawk affair and tables in
chinatown
where uncles play chess late into the
night tell different stories
our studio is located in the chinatown
kyungsik neighborhood
a cultural melting pot of historic shop
houses
and modern buildings five foot ways
reduce the scale of the city
into an intimate passage of rhythmic
arches
they are tailor-made for humans we can
interact with shops
look inside and appreciate the details
we love living in a city of contrast
where multiple diverse perspectives are
woven
into an eclectic tapestry
a lot of my work takes place in arab
street
a place where migrants have become
neighbors and in the case of elbows
carpets
my friends among the colorful carpets
the owners explained the differences
between machine-made
and hand-tuft rugs
it reminds us of the artisan families we
met in indonesia and india
each of them elbow deep in their craft
what really inspires us is seeing people
at work
whether it's a weaver on his step loom
orbitic artisan
applying steaming wax we respect the
dedication that goes into honing a craft
through the generations from grandfather
to father to son
the slow pace of handcrafting reminds us
that design
is a journey enriched by exploration and
seeming detours
it's okay to slow down and find rest
during my free time i like to attend
creative workshops where i learn
something new
the chapter at neil road is a space
where i slow down
and soak in the sights and smells of tea
brewing
having downtime allows me to come back
to the drawing board
with fresh perspectives
the textures of architectural facades
are a constant use
our modular print rope was inspired by
the eye-catching facets
of the concourse tropical facades are
designed
not just for aesthetics but also provide
shade and ventilation
reducing the need for artificial cooling
in fashion we ask the same question how
can we make use of the limited resources
we have to produce
something beautiful that doesn't harm
the earth
many of our artisans come from
agricultural communities
where rivers are often polluted by the
use of toxic dyes
we need to rethink the broken ecosystem
of fashion
like every ecosystem the needs are vast
and competing
we need to sit down and sift through
which values are foremost for us
the home is the main space where these
conversations are fostered
at the table with fellow creatives
nos comes from nostalgia which means a
longing for home
we create pieces that people feel at
home in
wherever they are